[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une mission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département est aujourd'hui mercredi
12 avril parole à frank e ville est le
président du festival l'ombre d'un cours
organisés dans quelques jours à jouy en
josas il nous présentera dans le détail
la huitième édition de ce festival
international de courts métrages 26
films sont en lice cette année pour la
compétition officielle
paroles aussi dans cette émission à sidy
diallo un marathonien yvelinois qui ne
s'arrête jamais de courir et pour cause
le sportif a participé à 152 course en
l'espace de sept ans particularité il
réalise ses exploits depuis quelques
années pieds nus il nous dévoilera une
partie de son secret mais on débute donc
cette émission avec du cinéma à des 21
et 22 avril prochain est organisée la 8e
édition du festival international de
courts métrages de jouy en josas une
trentaine de films sera projetée pendant
deux jours en cette édition plusieurs
réalisateurs en devenir ont été
découverts grâce à cet événement
certains ont même été récompensé aux
césar et aux oscars mélanie pau qui a
rencontré le président du festival
écoute et franceville est bonjour je
vous être le président et organisateur
du festival l'ombre d'un cours qui se
tiendra les 21 et 22 avril prochain
alors c'est la huitième édition déjà
quel est le programme alors le programme
est assez chargé alors bien sûr une
compétition de courts métrages comme
d'habitude compétition officielle les
compétitions jeunes publics
le jeune public qui a lieu le samedi
après midi de 14 heures à 17 heures et
avec 13 films d'animation et de fiction
et puis donc des films 23 23 à 26 films
en compétition
avec des récompenses à la clé et un jury
de professionnels qui qui sera là pour
pour décerner des prix et donc en huit
éditions toujours cet amour du court
métrage toujours toujours on continue on
est toujours passionnés ont chaque année
on découvre vraiment en plus des des
films toujours aussi bien toujours aussi
novateur on essaie de dénicher la perle
rare et on est toujours agréablement
surpris on est toujours content de le
faire est ce que vous vous rappelez vite
fait ce qui est un court métrage c'est
une question de durée
oui absolument il ya même moindre la
nomination de moyens métrages
alors le court et le moyen c'est entre
une minute et à 59 minutes et après on
passe au voulons métrage avec le court
métrage c'est plus jusqu'à entre voilà
jusqu'à 20 à 25 minutes nous on va
jusqu'à 20 minutes pour notre festival
la particularité de votre festival c'est
surtout la rencontre des professionnels
et du public c'est ça qui vous motive
depuis huit éditions voilà on essaie de
ne pas faire que de la projection c'est
aussi un festival sert aussi à faire des
rencontres notamment pour les
professionnels et les jeunes
réalisateurs qui présentent leurs films
c'est de rencontrer d'abord le public
bien sûr de voir comment le film à être
accueillis et puis aussi des
professionnels dans le cadre justement
de de constituer un jury
ils sont là aussi pour donner leur avis
et faire
faire évoluer aussi à la carrière de
réalisateur vous le disiez une trentaine
de courts métrages cette année une
trentaine choisi par une parmi un
millier de candidature en général
comment vous vous faites un choix ça
doit pas être facile mais à 23 26 films
cirque là on a battu un record encore
cette année on a reçu plus de mille ans
candidature avec notre partenaire la
plateforme la plateforme du court
métrage qui aulas qui gère un petit peu
les inscriptions tous les réalisateurs
peuvent s'inscrire des réalisateurs
étrangers aussi puisque c'est un
festival international et oui plus de
1000 films c est très compliqué beaucoup
de après il ya des choix subjectif
évidemment aimé ya quand même voilà on
essaie de voir l'aspect général à
technique la réalisation et puis
l'interprétation que aussi important et
le scénario alors après voilà on on
discute on échange ça débat
l'intérieur du comité et puis on arrive
j'espère un résultat
convenable des choses subjectif qui
révèlent parfois une carrière future
certains des participants aux éditions
précédentes ont été scénarisés le voir
oscarisé ouais c'est aussi un une belle
image pour votre festival
oui bah oui oui on essaie de
alors on le sait pas bien sûr à l'avancé
s'ils vont être sélectionnés aux césars
ou même aux oscars ça fait toujours
plaisir de constater qu'un film qui a
été scénarisé oscarisée est passé est
passé par le festival mais alors il ya
la rencontre avec le public
mais c'est un festival donc il ya des
remises de prix il y en a plusieurs
oui le plus prestigieux peut-être c'est
le grand prix le grand prix du jury
et puis à tous mais aussi un prix de la
mise en scène et on a ajouté cette année
le prix du film d'animation est ce que
c'est vrai que c'est toujours compliqué
comme il ya aussi de l'animation c'est
toujours compliqué de donner un avis sur
la fiction et sur l'animation c'est pas
du tout la même chose évidemment donc la
préférer à décerner un prix du film
d'animation il y aura aussi avec prix
d'interprétation il ya un prix du public
c'est important aussi que le public
donne son avis ils viennent aussi voir
des films des films et puis appuyez un
prix coup de coeur du festival que les
films à venir remettre
on a aussi beaucoup parlé du jury fait
venir des grands nombres gsm en tout cas
chaque année vous avez eu jean pierre
mocky elsa zylberstein par lbo et cette
année sam karmann sam karmann pourquoi
sam karmann alors pourquoi sam karmann
ce que c'est un très grand professionnel
acteurs
réalisateur et metteur en scène a
voilà et puis on cherche on cherche des
noms oui c'est important je pense aussi
pour le public que
rencontre des personnalités qui est que
ces personnalités
justement parlent de leur carrière de
leur de leur parcours c'est toujours
intéressant pour le public d'avoir
l'envers du décor comment s'est passée
un tournage voilà donc sam karmann en
président du jury et puis on aura
frédéric gorny aussi
il y aura aussi à l'ena braibant qui est
une actrice qui a tourné d'ailleurs avec
avec sam karmann et puis il y aura
marc-henri boullier qu'il resterait le
lauréat du prix du jury a donc de
l'année dernière avec juliette qu'on a
invité dans le jury et puis re agnès
vincent qui est une compositrice et
musicienne et puis karine geslain qui
est agent artistique
merci franceville est alors venu pour
découvrir les réalisateurs en devenir et
tous ces films courts métrages en
compétition
rendez vous les 21 et 22 avril prochain
au théâtre du vieux marché de jouy en
josas
on poursuit cette émission avec de la
course à pied et l'histoire plutôt
étonnante de sidy diallo habitants de
montigny le bretonneux
le coureur a terminé sans 52 marathons
ultramarathon sur 55 pays et sept
continents en tout juste six ans et demi
depuis quelques années le sportif de 61
ans a même décidé de retirer ses
chaussures pour courir pieds nus cre
notre journaliste michael et demi
d'euros l'a rencontrée juste avant son
départ pour le marathon de rotterdam il
ya quelques jours
regardez à mes côtés ligny montait à
sidy diallo qui a réalisé sans 51
marathons et ultra marathons dans sa vie
en six ans et demi alors pourquoi sidy
diallo pourquoi vous êtes vous lancé
dans cette aventure des marathons
ça y est assez récent finalement oui
c'est très simple je vais
55 ans à chicago où j'étais arrivé
deux années plus tôt et pendant
deux éditions du marathon de chicago
j'ai applaudi
des couleurs plus de 40000 qui passaient
des vaches moi des gens comme moi des
hommes et des femmes et des hommes comme
moi et 40000 personnes qui passent
devant chez vous qui sont en train de
courir 42 kilomètres carrés des bulles
de kilomètres ou de sept ans on se dit
mais s'il le faut je peux le faire
absolument et finalement comme le
premier marathon est ce arrivé quelques
mois après voilà en 2010 10 octobre 2010
et lommois la tournée chez kawa donc
j'ai décidé de d'être épargné les
couleurs pour que les autres aussi me
voir et qui se disent pourquoi pas eux
et ça vous a plu absolument et qui s'est
loupé d'un marathon non en faite le la
coach du marathon où les ultra marathon
c'est une simulation deux hommes
modernes de la chasse à l'épuisement
effectuer nos ancêtres ou qui
s'effectuent encore dans certains
endroits
de la planète et c'est un retour aux
sources
si je comprends bien ouais c'est retour
à la case départ parce qu'en fait quand
on court le marathon notre cerveau
reptilien il pense qu'on est en train de
chasser pour amener à manger à bb et à
la famille à la tribu et comme il sait
que les individus sont par définition
fainéants les individus de toutes les
espèces elles ne sont pas une exception
si on finira donc il faut les encourager
d'où la libération des endorphines qui
fait que les gens deviennent intrus
diomi à chromé s'est pas accru ses
confères de l'amour aussi parce qu'il
faut avoir des enfants pour la survie de
l'espèce
si le même genre de plaisir c'est
naturel c'est naturel assez libre vous
avez déjà réalisé sept marathons en sept
jours est ce que c'est possible
vous l'avez fait mais est ce que c'est
vraiment possible pour tout le monde a
connu une fois au logo d'origine 1
les gens vous raconte jean mais pis du
marathon parents mais c'est absurde nous
à 7 et pratiquer la chasse et
l'épuisement et c'était des courses de
longue distance en 2 découvre
d'endurance sans savoir quand ça se
termine alors que nous quand on commence
une course sans cesse et 42 km que ces
50 km il savait pas il fallait attraper
l'animal mais si la scop est pas parce
qu un autre prédateur supérieur à
l'avenue qu'ils ont eu peur que l'animal
a réussi à les semer
totalement le lendemain il fallait il
fallait repartir non que nos ancêtres
étaient capables de faire ses courses
tous les jours sur toute l'année donc à
nous en fait cette sas et débuta une
semaine si c'est du confort ça donc
c'est pas grand chose s'est dit confiant
son camp une préparation à il faut une
préparation parce qu'on est si vous
voulez le corps humain il le fait pour
les courses d'endurance où nous sommes
excellent nous sommes des piètres
sprinteurs je crois que le plus le plus
rapide c'est usain bolt je crois que
c'est le maximum sa main vitesse
maximale c'est 44 km à quelque chose
comme ça le quadrupède ils vont jusqu'à
120 kilomètres à plus de 120 km
donc nous sommes des piètres et sprinter
et nous serons aussi des pièces auteurs
voyez le chat
comment ils sont là ils sautent à des
auteurs qui sont plusieurs fois sa
taille
nous on peut pas les humains ne peuvent
pas par contre nous sommes d'excellents
coureurs de l'endurance et parce que
c'était une question de survie de notre
espèce
votre particularité ce sont vos pieds
vous courrez keenu vraiment les
compétitions pourquoi combat qui lui a
non mais ça sert à ça
c'est le sens de courir pieds nus parce
que les humains sont censés marcher et
courir pieds nus
fini bien marcher et courir pieds nus
non seulement on n'a pas besoin de
chaussures mais les chaussures ne font
que nous causer de problème quand on
court quant au marché à moins d'efforts
mais à la course ça ne pose que de
problèmes ça vous change la démarche
il atterrissait sur le talon le pied
droit
cela veut dire que d'où l'impact du
corps va directement au sol
effectivement si vous avez des
chaussures avec l avoir un peu
d'amortissement sera amorti un peu mais
c'est pas par contre si vous pourrez
pieds nus l'impact est réduit vous
atterrissez au milieu ou à l'avant des
pieds et toute la mécanique des pieds et
de la jambe est fait pour que l'impact
soit considérablement réduit et en plus
dans ce cas l'impact aussi c'est la
partie surtout les pieds au lieu que ce
soit uniquement sous le talon mais y'a
plein de choses il ya plein de choses
il ya aussi le fait que le pied la
sensibilité des pieds c'est pour sentir
le sort s'en tire le sol que pour que
les bonnes informations soit envahie au
cerveau sur le type de sol qu'on en
train de fouler et ça permet au cerveau
d'envoyer les bonne instruction au
système musculaire que ce soient les
bonnes contraction pour que la foulée
soient adaptées au sol avec les
chaussures il ya plus d'informations je
pense que quand l'hiver quand vous
mettez des gants vous perdez la
sensibilité des mains en plus les mêmes
qu'avec des gars souple les fonctions
demain sont réduites sont plus aussi
efficace
c'est la même chose qui vous porter des
chaussettes imaginez que vous portez des
galeries gîtes les mêmes ne savent plus
à lire les pieds c'est pareil avec les
chaussures en fait il sait absolument
depuis et les chaussures roses et les à
nouveau les enlever dans quelques jours
à rotterdam pour un nouveau marathon le
152e marathon puisque vous visez la non
non non non non non je les enlève pas je
l'aimé pas on était tous ces trois là
que je vais des chaussures
c'est fini ah si je suis ici l'hiver il
fait froid
si jamais dégagé mettrait des chaussures
mais des chaussures minimalistes
si je mets dégager mais je suivre
simenon merci beaucoup sidy diallo et
bon courage pour 650 le deuxième
marathon coq merci beaucoup merci à vous
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
retrouver toutes nos et quand son replay
sur notre site internet tv fil 78 points
comme ou l'application tv fil 78
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]